September 2018 I was tired I was
exhausted I just got back home from
something and I didn't have the energy
to cook so I went to my phone I opened
up a certain food delivery app that's
popular in the UK and I ordered pizza
now I know that food delivery companies
employment practices are questionable
there are more ethical ways to get
dinner delivered but I was tired now as
hungry as are a lot of their drivers but
that was the night of the multiple
orders when a bug in that app meant that
some people around Britain ended up with
identical food orders being delivered
two or three times and others got
nothing at all and I nearly got caught
up in the chaos to explain what happened
I need to tell you a story about two
generals the two generals problem is a
classic of computer science in it goes
like this
picture of Valley in the middle of the
valley is a heavily fortified castle on
the edges of the valley are two armies
the generals of those armies know that
the only way they can win a battle and
overwhelm the castle is if they both
attack at the same time a single army
isn't going to make it they need the
combined strength from both sides of the
valley to win and the only way they can
communicate is by sending messengers on
a risky path through the valley and
general I won't know what the right time
to attack is until everyone is already
in position how can those two generals
coordinate to make sure they attack at
the same time this is a magical computer
science latin problem by the way so
reasonable suggestions like semaphore or
telescopes don't apply on the surface
the problem seems trivial general I can
just send a message to general B where
the proposed time say 8 o'clock but the
messenger has to pass through the valley
and if they're spotted there I'm not
going to make it to the other side to
deliver the message so how does general
a know that general B received the
message the messenger might not have
made it and if that happens able attack
B won't and they'll lose so maybe they
arranged it so that general B has to
send an acknowledgement back and general
a well on the attack if that
acknowledgment arrives but that now runs
into the same problem how does B know
that a has received the acknowledgment
if it doesn't get through a won't attack
B will and lose so general aid could
send another acknowledgment for the
acknowledgment but how do they know that
that mess
has gotten through well general B could
send an acknowledgement for the
acknowledgement for the acknowledgement
and so on and so on and so on this
problem is unsolvable I know it feels
like there should be some hanky work
around like sending 200 messengers I'm
sure that would probably work in the
real world but this is magical
information theory computer science land
under these strict rules there is never
a guarantee there is no certainty no
arrangement that can be made there is no
way that the two generals the two
computers sending data can agree that
the message has definitely been received
and acknowledged now with computers
you're not usually dealing with such
high stakes if you are in computer
science and work on a problem that
involves potential loss of life I really
hope you aren't watching series called
the basics anyway I was ordering food
and I put my order together and I tapped
pay I put my fingerprint on the phones
reader I got a little Apple pay progress
bar and a little tick and then I got a
message from the amp saying that there
had been a problem and my order had
failed to go through what I'd like to
try again and I was about to I was about
to hit pay again and then something just
just in the back of my head said hang on
that was that little tick saying payment
had worked and I'm enough of a computer
nerd to go I'm not sure I believe that
that failed so I checked the order
history page it took a few tries to load
but when it finally did there was my
order processing it had gone through but
the acknowledgment hadn't come back or
rather something had gone wrong on the
app servers and the logic they'd written
thought it had failed when it happened
so I sat tight I hoped that my food
would arrive and I figured that the
engineers were probably having a very
bad day they really were because I
wasn't the only one people all over the
UK ordering via the Apple game go to the
payment screen hitting the button and
getting try again and a lot of them did
and Ken and again and again
they were general a and the app server
was general B and they were part of a
real-life complicated version of the two
generals problem imagine all the
customers as general a sending message
after message to general B being
received the messages dutifully took the
money from the credit card every time
they they attacked but something had
happened that stopped the confirmation
message getting through according to the
flood of angry reports on Twitter
sometimes the restaurant would realize
the problem and just send one order
sometimes the restaurant wouldn't
realize and three different drivers
would arrive with three identical orders
sometimes no food would arrive at all
the apps customer service line was
swamped to be clear this was not the
sort of thing that is one engineer's
fault when something goes this
drastically wrong there have been many
poor decisions made over a long period
of time a single human error is never a
root cause so what else could the app
team have done how can you solve the two
generals problem in the real world
well first maybe no one should have been
able to place two identical orders on
the same credit card for the same
restaurant within a few minutes of each
other that seems like the sort of thing
there should have been a check for but
the real solution is an identity token
or an identity key that's a unique value
generated on the app or on the website
and it's a shopping cart ID basically
and it's sent along with the order it's
not just for shopping carts though the
idem potency token could be attached to
instructions to delete the oldest log
file or send a text message or anything
that you only want to happen once the
server stores the identity key to keep
track of the request and if another
request arrives with the same key
attached then the server knows it's
already dealt with that request so it
doesn't fulfill it again instead it
knows that the reply didn't get through
so it just sends back a copy of that
first technology meant again now that
still won't help if none of the
messengers get through if the connection
completely fails but for real-world
problems humans will notice that idem
pitous means that you can request the
same thing multiple times and it'll only
ever happen was that's the way to fix
the two generals problem I was lucky I
placed one order I was charged for one
order and one order of food arrived half
an hour later next time I'll just cook
for myself this series of the basics is
sponsored by - Lane the password manager
I mentioned in the previous sponsored
section that they sync all your
passwords and payment details between
all your devices without ever knowing
those passwords which sounds a bit like
magic when you sign up - - Lane you
choose a master password and
incidentally you can do that by going to
- lang comm / Tom Scott for a free
30-day trial anyway when you sign up you
a single master password and that is
never transmitted over the Internet not
even to dashlane not their servers
nowhere if you don't know that password
all that private data just looks like
random noise so when you sign up to a
new website and dashlane generates a
long complicated password for you it is
bundled up and encrypted using your
master password that only you know that
encryption takes just long enough a few
fractions of a second but there's no way
to brute-force it back open that
encrypted bundle gets sent to dash line
they just seem random noise with a label
saying please synchronize this so they
pass the bundle on to your other devices
and those devices and only those devices
can decrypt it because at some point
you're going to open up the app and type
in your master password in truth it's
actually a little more secure than that
because behind the scenes they also
generate a different key for each device
you login to but that is a whole other
level of security that I have actually
found it impossible to explain in a
stripped but in the massively unlikely
event that someone did compromise
dashlane servers or bribe some employee
it wouldn't work all they could do is
watch those packets of random noise get
shuffled around all your data stays on
your own devices which means if you lose
your master password - Lane can't help
you but that's fine because now you've
just got a single password to remember
that is massively more secure than
reusing the same password or variations
everywhere online like I said last time
you should use a password manager so -
Lane comm slash Tom Scott for a free
30-day trial - flame premium and if you
like it you can use the code Tom Scott
for 10% off code purchase